when we think of the Crusades we think
of Kings Knights and peasants from
places like France England and the Holy
Roman Empire marching to the Holy Land
to retake important Christian cities but
during the time of the Crusades to the
south of the eubid sultanates at the
Nubian Christian kingdoms of dottowo and
arua and to their South was Ethiopia it
won't surprise you to know that these
kingdoms also didn't get along with
their Islamic Neighbors which raises an
obvious question when the Crusades
kicked off did they get involved did
these African kingdoms take part in the
Crusades so when the First Crusade was
called the Christians of Europe knew
very little about those in Africa
Christians from Nubia Ethiopia and
Arabia had traveled to the Holy Land on
pilgrimages however these were just seen
as individual Christians not as
representatives of potential allies in
fact the Crusaders just saw Africans as
subjects of the EU bids and even after
the first crusade had conquered
Jerusalem contact between the two groups
was rare it was during the Third Crusade
that the relationship between Europeans
and Nubians began to flourish and the
Crusaders started to realize that unlike
their fellow coptics in Egypt these
Christians were free of Muslim oversight
and thus were a potential ally and the
EU bids desperately tried to stop this
relationship from blossoming this was
mostly because its leaders were worried
about the two uniting and attacking from
both sides which was fairly logical
because as the Third Crusade was ongoing
this is exactly what happened whilst
Richard the lionheart was doing his
thing King Moses who had briefly United
Ottawa and arua invaded Egypt Saladin
retaliated but wasn't able to strike a
killing blow because every time he
invaded the Crusaders in the Northwood
attack this wasn't coordinated or
anything it's just that whenever troops
had to move away to deal with the other
threat it presented an opportunity to
invade Beyond this though there isn't
any evidence to suggest that African
Christians were fighting in the Crusades
proper in any great numbers just that
the two groups were growing ever more
aware of each other by contact in
Jerusalem it was the fifth crusade which
saw the height of European hopes with
respect to African Christians when the
Crusaders landed in Egypt there was a
hope that a major Nubian Army would
March North they'd then conquer Egypt
together before turning their Collective
attention to the Holy Land slight hiccup
with this plan though the Nubians
weren't aware of any of this so
obviously couldn't act on it the help
didn't come the Crusaders were defeated
and contact between the two groups came
to a near halt when Jerusalem fell again
in 1244 and after this the EU bid soon
turned their full attention to daughtero
which fractured and converted several
decades later arua fell The Next Century
to an invasion from Arabia and also
converted soon afterwards some fled from
these kingdoms and ended up in Cyprus
which left only Ethiopia again
Christians had little idea of where it
actually was or even if it existed at
all which meant the said relationship
went nowhere at least until Europeans
returned to the continent in the 19th
century with one notable exception in
the mid-15th century there was an
attempt to reunite the Western and
Eastern churches during these
discussions the pope invited Christians
from all over the world to Florence to
attend the meeting and the idea of both
attacking the ottomans at the same time
was put forward the plan was to retake
the holy land and restore the byzantines
but this obviously didn't happen mostly
because the Ethiopian Kingdom at this
time was much smaller than the
Christians thought it was and with this
being a no-go it marked an end to the
Crusades in any potential African
involvement with them I hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons James bizonette Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle call show wolf Jordan
Longley Adam's daughter Jerry lambdin
Marcus Arsenal words about books podcast
rod D Martin why in hockey Marvin cassow
Spencer Lightfoot boogly Wiggly Winston
K wood Captain sidor Community Gustav
Swan Daniel to be in misses it Aaron the
white Matthew Shipley Maggie Paskowski
Alex Schwinn Corey Turner Anthony
Beckett Coppertone shawanin spinning
three plates the mcquopter and Charles
the first